[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN GALPIN: Hi, and welcome
back to "The Developer Show's"
coverage at GDD India.
I'm Dan Galpin here
with Florina Muntenescu.
And she's been working
with Android developers
around the world, particularly
with Architecture Components.
Now, how does Architecture
Components change the way
Google relates to
Android development?
FLORINA MUNTENESCU:
Well, together
with a set of
Architecture Components,
we're also releasing a
guide to Architecture.
So for a long time,
developers have
been asking us what's the
right way of architecting
our application?
Because, especially in Android,
we have a lot of patterns--
MVC, MVP, MVVM, MVI, MVC--
yeah.
So developers wanted,
well, what's the right way?
And then we released the Guide
to App Architecture, which
suggests a way of doing that.
But most importantly,
what it suggests
is having things separate and
testable and easy to extract.
DAN GALPIN: What's
the biggest benefit
of the lifecycle-aware
components?
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: We saw
that there were some things
that developers tend to
do over and over again,
and one thing is
having components
that we have based
on the lifecycle.
So for example, you start
subscribing or listening
to location services based on
when the activities started.
Or you want to stop
when the activity is
no longer in program.
This was initially
part of the activity.
But now, you can separate
that in a different class.
And that class can
be, now, unit tested.
So again, it's all about the
stability and separation.
DAN GALPIN: How does Vroom alter
the typical ways developers
work with databases?
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: Well, to
be honest, for a long time
I was avoiding databases
as much as possible.
And what I didn't like
was that it was so much
boilerplate I needed to write,
all of those cursor.getInt,
cursor.getString.
And then you keep on
writing, and then you
keep on Copy, Pasting.
And if you're like me, you
can end up doing mistakes.
So all of that boilerplate
that you need to write now
is just gone because
Vroom does all
of that object mapping for you.
And again, apart
from that, it also
comes with a high
degree of flexibility,
so not only on
creating the tables,
working with the
queries, and so on,
but also with migrations
because our app always evolves.
So you want to make sure
that when the database
schema changes, we also provide
something that's stable,
that's robust, that our users
don't have a problem with.
DAN GALPIN: Many of the
components are already at 1.0,
but you talked about the Paging
Library here at GDD India.
Now, what does it do?
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: In India, we
released already the components
to be announced at Google
I/O are already in 1.0.
They're already stable.
But we saw that there's
more need for components.
So we started working
on the Paging Library.
That's now in our focus.
We're still in working
progress with it.
So what developers had was
data coming from a data
source, database
network, and that they
don't need it to be displayed
on a screen, on a list.
And then, the role
of the Paging Library
is to make this connection
between the data source
and the RecyclerView
as easy as possible.
But I was saying that
it's [INAUDIBLE]..
So this means that
this is your chance
to help us shape the library,
as you did with the Architecture
Components so far.
You've done such a
great job giving us
feedback, telling us what's
missing, what kind of issues
we have, what kind of stuff you
expect to be there but are not.
Please do the same with
the Paging Library,
and tell us how it can make
everything easier for you.
DAN GALPIN: I know you've been
talking a lot with developers
here in India.
Was there any interesting
insight you found out
about the local
market and things
that Indian developers
have to do to target it?
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: So I heard
that there are applications
here that actually have, as
part of their app icon label,
something that says less
than two megabytes or less
than three megabytes because
that's the size of APK.
I think we've been spoiled
with the device size
and with the network.
And we don't realize that,
hey, outside our bubble,
people really care
about the data
and really care about
the size of the APK.
So developers here end up
doing a lot of really awesome
optimizations on the APK size.
I actually even talked
with a few of them,
and it's going to
come out later.
But I promise I'll give
you a lot of insights
on what developers here do,
also, to optimize their APK
size and other, in general,
Android best practices, which
for them are a must.
They're not just a should.
DAN GALPIN: That's great.
So now, where can
developers go to learn more
about Paging Library and
the rest of the Architecture
Components?
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: On
developers.android.com we
have extensive documentation
on the Architecture Components.
We have advice on how to use the
components and in which cases.
And even more, if you're
looking for code samples,
check out the
googlesamples/android
architecture components.
You'll find there
six or seven projects
that target different specific
problems that Architecture
Component solves.
DAN GALPIN: Well, that's great.
Thank you so much for
chatting with us, Florina.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU:
Thank you for having me.
DAN GALPIN: Please visit
the description below
if you'd like to learn more
about the Paging Library
preview and the rest of the
Architecture Components.
And stay tuned for Florina's
on the ground developer
interviews here in India.
Once again, I'm Dan Galpin
reporting from "The Developer
Show" from GDD India.
[MUSIC PLAYING]